[Music]
testing check one check two hot route
this is Matt Ryan is this working stop
yelling just turn it around
well a few of us have experienced an
unusual amount of activity so we thought
we'd move in together and figure out
what's going on
bedtime
[Music]
let's ride see right there a chandelier
clearly falls on Russell Wilson I would
have avoided it but I've been sleeping
injured for weeks and look at this
oh that's just coaches game plan oh yeah
that's right Danny really just throw
your body around all willy-nilly
this is just part of the process I'm not
even being haunted sure about that
here Devonta Freeman let's just run the
ball
[Music]
I'm giving myself up fine put Ellinger
in so you really think we're being
haunted by demon yes what is clearly the
ancient demon Matthew judon I called in
some protection indeed I can already
feel the presence of the demon we need
to prepare ourselves
oh demon out Michael Morrisons by the
power of Trent Williams I expel you
I didn't throw these picks I swear
Joe Thomas
oh hey Nick yellow what do we do if
you're being attacked by demon you need
to move I don't understand like give up
and get out okay listening to teammate
feedback and we're staying I refuse to
scramble it
no oh no
no I'm sorry who are you Alex hi Smith
I'm having a really nice season for the
Steelers you know our media just doesn't
do right by you defensive guys right how
do I not have a single weapon
what was that I heard nobody believes in
me why are you attacking me you're
supposed to go through my manager
Now give me that I want to watch the
film on this one
and that's why we must do everything we
can
to stop the d-man
oh so scary